außergewöhnliche gäste heute bei pixum
bevor ich also die frage wie ist die
lage stelle
wir haben heute die leute hier die eine
extrem erfolgreiche facebook seite mache
das heißt ihre seite ist berühmt ihr
selber seit es noch nicht so richtig
aber das ändert sich heute mit diesem
topf und wer seid ihr da eine lehre war
der microbus so gerne ich bin dabei
wie ist die lage ganz guten immer micro
immer wieder so immer neben haben ja die
lage ist ganz gut wir freuen uns dass
wir hier sind ein bisschen länger
gebraucht dass wir hier kopf hinkommen
aber schmeckt ja eine andere fan seite
die ist dann im rahmen der besprechung
terminfindung ist er dann von facebook
abgeschaltet worden
wie ist das risiko wie sieht das bei
euch aus besteht ein risiko oder seid
ihr sicher bei uns ja wir sind ziemlich
sicher aber es halt bei facebook immer
so dass man mal was posted was
vielleicht an schließlich einen kleinen
gruppen sind dann melde das ganz schnell
kennst du bist vielleicht auch dass die
ich kenne das nicht nein nein wir uns
wir posten doch mal so schwarzem humor
zwischendurch und für manche leute ist
das dann eher an schließlich so
moralapostel in der richtung und jade
melden dass dann ist man vielleicht für
24 stunden blockiert aber dann machte er
es dann weiter und aber es passiert
nicht mehr so häufig okay dieses
überhaupt dazu gekommen
ihr habt ihr angefangen ja das ist eine
lange geschichte ist kann in der
kurzform ja es waren auch also ein guter
freund das ist mittlerweile im kongo
lebt hat irgendwann sich gedanken
gemacht da waren wir schon typ der
ziemlich auf internet und hier
plattformen wie facebook und damals auch
network fixiert war auf jeden fall hat
er sich gedacht einfach mal so eine
seite zu machen dazu ist es dann
irgendwie auch gekommen lief dann am
anfang ein bisschen ja
langsamer verständlicherweise aber
irgendwann sagt 20.000 likes unglaublich
so irgendwie der scheitert klick gemacht
genau der heutigen los ist ein bisschen
selbstläufer mäßig geworden die leute
haben gesehen dass digital die
reichweite ist gestiegen und das hat
sich dann irgendwie ganz schon
weiterentwickelt jetzt bei knapp 400.000
gleich sind es läuft sogar die ganze
wollte eigentlich nur diese dürften die
freie wahl gab die wollte auch haben
dann fanden wir das eigentlich ganz
witzig weil du mal schwarz grün hat
perfekt gepasst
und da dann ist das so selbstläufer
geworden ist wo ist ja auch ziemlich
bekannt soja und welche blauen schriften
wollte er das hat ja früher gab es diese
blauen schriften wie gefällt mir
nur weil du geil bist oder so gerade
hatten wir unter dem motto kommentare
posten konnte und ja dann hatten wir das
halt für uns hatten wir dann auch mal
schwarz belegen dass gepostet hat oder
soja spender oder so dann nur als
schwarze also so ein kleiner fluss
christen sind eigentlich standen also so
kleinen spruch ist dann die ganze seite
ich dann das eigentlich nur als scherz
gedacht war und sich ganz dann
weiterentwickelt ist ein bisschen
rasanter jahre später als er selbst
erwartet hätten weil es stellt man ganz
- mit konsum
ja so war das okay warum macht er das
warum also ich denke mal jetzt
mittlerweile ist es schon soweit wir
haben ja wirklich klappt eine reichweite
von 4 6 millionen arbeitslosen wir sind
näher an vier bis sechs millionen pro
woche und da ist ja wirklich schon so
dass man halt auch noch erreicht das
heißt auch wenn wir jetzt mal sachen
posten die uns persönlich wichtig sind
oder uns beschäftigen du hast du
erreichst und dass man schon ziemlich
viel spaß natürlich gibt man auch nicht
nur positive rückmeldungen aber alles
feedback ist ehrlich gesagt für uns
einfach nur ein bisschen was
interessiert es gegenüber gezeigt wird
und haben spaß daran einfachen leute ein
bisschen kommunizieren zu können ein
bisschen plattform zu haben mit der wir
leute reichen können das ist eigentlich
schon sinn und zweck der sache gewesen
und wir können uns noch mal vorbereiten
aber selbst immer was zu lachen weil in
den kommentaren passiert meist etwas
lustigeres halt ja die post und witzig
und dann diskutieren die leute darunter
halten noch
und geben selbst sprüche ab und ja
gefeiert das und wir lachen uns selbst
gegenseitig wo so ein zeug was der
letzte gepostet hat und was der letzte
kommentar den weg stream von ok jetzt
habt ihr so ein riesen reichweite 76 bis
3 millionen
drei bis vier also auf jeden fall
millionen reichweite empfindet ihr euch
auch schon ich sag mal als jemand der
die meinung beurteilt denkt ihr oft
schon nach wenn er was posted und das
ist thomas das können wir nicht oder wie
geht er damit um
also doch manchmal ist es wirklich dann
ja das ist halt so dass man total gegen
die masse stößt aber ich zum beispiel
ich poste das meistens nur was ich
selbst für relevant halten
postet das dann abends oder so dass ich
dann halt eine diskussionsrunde statt
gestern zum beispiel über träume
das merkt man der inhalt ich habe eine
ctf der kommunikation gesehen
und ja hat eigentlich nur noch das
bestätigt so was ich schon im laden
halte nix positiv also nicht so viel
so ganz ehrlich so und dann habe ich
eine kleine diskussion mit den fans und
so und die haben dann halt ihre meinung
noch gesagt und fand ich ein ganz guter
austausch so was man halt sieht wie man
unsere generation so ein bisschen tickt
und ist ja so ähnlich wie wir
und ja manchmal halt nicht so jetzt seid
ihr meint meistens eine große reichweite
hat dann kennen einen die leute euch
kennen die nicht wie sind so die
reaktion wenn er mal mit leuten sprechen
und sagt ja wir sind übrigens die die
nur weil ich schwarz bin machen ja also
wir sind jetzt eigentlich nicht so dass
ich die gegend laufen sagen ja wir sind
das andere sein sondern mal ja an sich
also es kommt schon häufig also wir
werden tatsächlich auch schon erkannt so
nein ja tatsächlich seit langen also
paar mal alle drei monats post ab und zu
mal bilder von uns angefragt werden so
wäre das eigentlich das ganze betreibt
ja erst werden jedenfalls ist dann schon
immer also dann wird man schon so
ziemlich gefeiert tatsächlich also
geschafft haben das selbst nicht so
denkt weil wir eigentlich nur facebook
and eggs treiben aber ist dann schon so
passt ihr seid das nur weil ich warte
weiter so ist das dann schon also es
gibt schon ziemlich positive reaktionen
dann wenn man das
das wissen auch manchem bekannt gar
nicht und eine arme bruder macht erhält
die seite und halt auch mal was davon
und ist dann halt immer ganz nett zu
hören so aber man ist dann halt immer so
ein bisschen fast peinlich peinlich
berührt soweit ich weiß war sagt soll
weil passiert ja nicht jeden tag so und
ja was machen was macht der eigentlich
sie haben einmal außerhalb dessen seite
er studiert er damals ausbildung wie
leere schule ja wir studieren und dann
halt das leben war das schon jetzt die
studie bewährt bwl auch warte ich auch
gar nicht zusammen halt total vorteile
vorteilhafter ist er ja auch aber es hat
es ganz interessant ist was ein fast
schon geht es los
ich liebe dich ich mache eine ausbildung
auch ganze wand besucher im alter
kaufmann ok gemacht chemie und englisch
auf lehramt
ok jetzt gerade mein erstes semester
angefangen bis jetzt läuft noch auch
wenn chemie ich gemerkt habe ein
bisschen naja ok das heißt ich hatte
oder ich sage euch gefragt was stellen
die leute sind sie sich vorher hinter so
einer seite steckt genau also viele vor
allem wenn wir mal gerade bilder gepasst
haben waren tatsächlich überrascht dass
wir das dann immer schon so also es war
schon ein bisschen heftig wenn wir jetzt
nicht
aber ja an sich ist das schon immer ja
die sind ziemlich ja die sind erstaunt
und ja es wird sich was also obwohl man
schon ein paar mal zwei drei mal gemacht
hat dass sie immer noch erstaunt zogen
dann kommt trotzdem noch so seid ihr
wirklich schwarz und hätte jetzt gar
nicht gesagt oh cool und so natürlich
kommen auch manchmal blöde sprüche und
so das aber muss man abkönnen
nein genau bisher ist ja grundsätzlich
so heutzutage dass manche hält manche
geben halt positive kritik zum beispiel
wenn man was posted und dann muss man
halt genau differenzieren was wollte er
damit den vorwurf machen zukunft ja der
jan ist ja auch bei uns dabei so der
noch ein paar videos und wir gehen jetzt
ein bisschen auch noch in die youtube
schiene
ja wer jetzt noch ganz cool dass man
halt mal sieht was wieso alltag so
machen wir machen auch wirklich coole
sachen du weißt du dann mal unterwegs
und treffen jetzt demnächst jacko den
rapper was ist den staaten der
komplettierung machten ja macht halt
sein concerto hier und da sind wir dann
auch bei und treffe ihn weil ich feiere
sein musik extrem und deswegen fand ich
das ganz gut dass wir das angebot
geprägt hatten dh er schreitet mehr so
hinterher
also es ist wirklich so eine
facebook-seite ist ein sprungbrett um
daraus zu machen
erstmals durch die reichweite bietet
sich natürlich an weil man ja ist denn
das ganze so ein bisschen finanziell
gesehen sondern der plattform facebook
nicht viel erreichen kann
genau deswegen nutzen wir also wie
gesagt wirklich schon als sprungbrett zu
wollen jetzt mal langsam auf die youtube
schiene wechseln sondern mal gucken mit
unseren usern unseren fans also gesagt
die wir jetzt schon haben wie die darauf
reagieren wird uns freuen natürlich wenn
das gut ankommt ich meine sind
eigentlich schon ein paar sympathische
paar am verlinken wir natürlich etwa
verlinken wir natürlich unten im
infotext also kann man gucken oder auch
hier eine anmerkung gerne anschauen kann
man mal gucken was er so macht ja klar
wird es freuen und in welche richtung
wird das gehen weil das nur reallife was
passiert euch so oder zum teil das zum
teil interviews und zum teil an auch
mittlerweile also wirklich schon was wir
so machen weil er wirklich also wir sind
schon ein bisschen komisch drauf
eigentlich also ich denke es lohnt sich
schon manchmal auch weil uns aufzunehmen
weil sich doch manchmal bei moment ja
legendäre momente die wir leben ja halt
crazy sachen die passieren so halt vom
beim feiern oder so dann sind wir ja
auch ganz schön oft aktiv in dortmund
halt auch so
wir haben also willen fenster auf kipp
gestellt weil es sonst weiß ist es warm
raus aber so stürmisch ist ein deswegen
gewinn wird sie ab und zu machen ja und
dann haben wir die situation wo wir am
nächsten tag und sand oder bzw sonntags
meistens dann auch treffen und dann sagt
das und das passiert weil wir sind auch
eine große gruppe wir sind meistens so
fünf bis acht leute und dann verteilen
wir uns halt im klub und dann sagt
erzählt der eine was was sie über ihr
passiert ist und der andere bohrer das
und das ist halt ziemlich witzig sein
altkreis sehen wer wem wer ist denn der
kern seid ihr drei der kern oder gehören
noch mehr dazu an sich also mit unseren
kollegen setzt hat im kongo ist das
jetzt schon so die kerngruppe es waren
ab und zu noch ein paar andere art
minister dann wieder nicht auf jeden
fall sind wir aber wir sind halt
meistens mit unseren freunden zusammen
so und die viel kontakt mit dem wir
jetzt wegen unserer seite nach innen wo
feiern sind oder info eingeladen werden
dann in wir halt wenn schon die ganze
gruppe mit da sind wir schon so und was
passiert da was sind die folgen meist
passiert durch die seite auch durch die
seite haben wir eigentlich sagt schon ja
wir sind auf konzerte eingeladen worden
backstage eingeladen im klubs auch schon
wie alles drum und dran die musikfreunde
mit was noch was man noch alles
wir sind auch mit dem modelabel zu
manchmal auch sagen so und so und dass
wir dann halt super sofort noch junge
talente also auch sowie ihr halt bloß
dass wir halt dann einfach nur bei uns
auf der facebook seite posten und die
dann halt eine neue reichweite erreichen
und selbst ihr unternehmen sagen wir mal
oder ihre abonnenten steigern und das
zeigt dann für die auch cool so und für
uns auch weil wir die sachen selbst auch
feiern also ihr habt jetzt gesprochen
der arbeitet man im boden leben oder
auch zusammen
ihr könnt ihr schon davon also irgendwas
damit ein ja schon also ist sie schon
kurz taschen ein gutes taschengeld aber
also ist noch im bereich taschengeld ja
ist auf jeden fall noch ungerechter
studiert aber auf jeden fall zum feiern
und zum überleben
in unserem alter aus den bereichen so
was natürlich aber wir arbeiten uns
langsam stetig hoch auf das was ist euer
zukunftsplan würdet ihr wir haben ja
gerade schon darüber gesprochen
glaubt ihr dass er ist ja mal irgendwann
mal berühmte entertainer seit oder wohin
kann sowas führen wohin kann der
facebook seite führen also ganz ehrlich
ich pushen oder so aber wir wollen jetzt
nicht wir wollen wissen was mit youtube
machen und dann halt ein bisschen zeigen
so aus unserem leben
ansonsten eigentlich ist das hobbymäßig
es ist halt unser hobby es macht uns ja
auch wirklich spaß die posten für posten
nicht einfach nur weil es schlicht nicht
weil wir so viele abonnenten haben
sondern es macht einfach wirklich spaß
so also ich bin die leute halt
nachrichten schicken schreibt dann auch
ab und an mit denen und unterhaltung
nicht mit denen und die jahrzehnte halt
so ein paar sachen und ja ich habe mega
spaß daran hat den kontakt mit den zu
pflegen und zu gucken wo es hingeht ist
halt in die sterne gegriffen
aber ihr seid zu allem bereit wir sind
zu allem bereit
diesmal konnten
was habt ihr denn oder meint ihr dass es
wirklich an euren persönlichkeiten liegt
dass das so erfolgreich geworden ist
also würdet ihr sagen wenn man eine gute
erfolgreiche facebook seite machen will
muss man auch humor haben muss man
irgendwie ein fable dafür haben oder
könnte das jeder so richtig kann aus
jeder aber doch man muss auf jeden fall
humor haben den man wo man womit man die
generation trifft halt weil es gibt es
ja wirklich etliche facebook-seiten und
wir werden auch tagtäglich angeschrieben
um eine seite und so ja man muss einfach
wirklich den um also ich poste nur das
was ich selbst wo ich selbst bin und
darüber lache oder welche halt im alltag
was was mir passiert ist oder so ja ich
denke das kommt auch so zusammen vor
allem was jetzt eine gruppe von mehreren
admins weil halt viele seiten von einem
einzigen betrieben werden bei uns kommen
halt haben wir alle natürlich auch ein
bisschen anderen und jeder trifft damit
zu seine persönliche zielgruppe noch mal
von unserer seite aus sodass wir denke
ich schon eine ganz lustige mischung
damals szenen endeffekt was dabei
schätze ich mal ja nicht nur für
schwarze das heißt vielleicht so weiß
schwarz blau weiß wirklich nicht was
schwarz weil das werden wir auch oft
gefragt
dadurch sei das heißt wenn ich das neue
erfolgsrezept zusammensetze
zusammenzähle korrigiert mich wenn ich
falsch liege
also man muss humor haben sie haben muss
selber schutzfähig sein ich glaube wenn
man selber oder meine vermutung wäre
wenn man nicht selber witzig ist kleine
witzige ideen hat funktioniert ja ich
das schätzt das zweite ist man sollte
vielleicht zu mehreren sein damit man
ich sage mal breiter auch von verwirrung
gründung trifft und was würde dir noch
sagen
sind das die beiden punkte konsequenz
das schon jetzt einfach eine konsequenz
heißt wirklich es gibt viele die posten
vielleicht mal zwei drei sachen fürs und
sachen merken dann okay jetzt habe ich
knapp 200 leistet läuft nicht mehr so in
thailand auf aber wirklich das
dranbleiben ist da wirklich das
wichtigste also wenn man wirklich tag
der islam ist auch schon richtig
strukturiert also habe schon unsere
wo jeder so und so viele sachen postet
weil das wirklich schon so ist als man
merkte die reichweite steigt und sinkt
das ja immer stetig so ein wechsel also
da muss man schon dran bleiben damit das
auch wirklich läuft
dh ihr macht das fliegen wie viele
unserer kanäle auf gehabt wir sind
verhaltet euch wie ein sender genau wird
es gibt einen plan dann wirken muss
ausgebaut werden
also so ungefähr nur ein bisschen
kleineren form hat ja aber eigentlich
schon und wir machen das habe den
schichtdienst heute morgen du ja
eigentlich schon also jeder hat so seine
aufgaben zu erfüllen der eine pause
beispielsweise videos der andere sprüche
der andere bilder und mittlerweile also
es gab dabei weil wir eigentlich schon
ziemlich verteilte manchmal also schon
paar von uns wirklich einige seiner
vergessen mittlerweile haben wir das
ganze so im griff bekommen das ist schon
ziemlich flüssig läuft und hat sich das
ausgewirkt als er das so wirklich im
griff wir sind da die quoten nach oben
gegangen ja eigentlich schon also als
sie irgendwann so gemerkt haben das
mussten wir uns natürlich die mischung
ist an bildern also irgendwann merkt man
okay das kommt gut an das läuft bei dem
limit sollten wir vielleicht breit
bleiben verurteilt damit das irgendwie
gut ankommt und damit es nicht zu viel
wird und das zeigt sich dann auch an den
zahlen jedenfalls also das ist auf jeden
fall so dass man sagen kann stetig
steigt die anzahl der fans abonnenten
wie auch immer und das geht eigentlich
weiter immer nach oben so also dass
geister wir mit mehr weiß wohin das noch
führt
falls euer lieblings post das ist das
ist ja das ist eine gute frei wenn jetzt
hast du gefragt also wirklich was du
liebst klingt ist ja wirklich
wöchentlich unterschiedlich was dann
hier posten und
aber die situation die er kennt seinen
beispielen was sagen jeder kühlschrank
nach wird auch wert der nun hat er mit
kosten zwischen rhein sowas einfach zum
beispiel ist sehr schön dann das war
sehr spannend
ich bin mal gespannt ob der ein oder
andere zugehört hat und jetzt ein plan
hat wie man auch so erfolgreich wird
gibt euch mir die konkurrenz ist groß
ja ist er groß ist es nicht so wenn die
konkurrenz ist groß
oben die luft dünner ja aber der ist es
halt wirklich riesig wie sich deswegen
sehen wir große seiten gibt es
eigentlich in deutschland also große
seiten wie also die ich zum beispiel
folge sind zehn glaube ich oder so 5 bis
5 5 könnt ihr euch endlich auffahren die
konkurrenten sind wir haben zu viel aber
wir sind auch mit partner freuen wir
haben genau kennt ihr euch untereinander
leben wählen sagt überwand leon ist mit
mit toni und lagerhalle
ich liebe mischlinge ja dass man tauscht
sich halt aus und man ist befreundet und
ja man projekt hat gab es schon mal
treffen nationen zusammen geschrieben
dazu fällt was ein unternehmen oder
sowas zusammenarbeiten das was man
daraus machen wird auch schon mal aus
dem staube mischlinge und auch eine
berühmte seite mit dem wir kontakt aber
jetzt als wissen
daran geliebt auf jeden fall mit denen
man ganz cool dann ist man zusammen
feiern
und ja silvester waren wir letztes jahr
mit dem mit ja genau mittig neben
mischlinge der in ihrer veranstaltung
und der hat uns eingeladen und wir waren
dann feiern und haben wir ja dann halt
gelebt
also fand ich unglaublich spannend ich
glaube ich mache jetzt einfach
irgendwann aber ich habe wirklich die
krux ist dran bleiben drohten brauchen
euch auch so und hier absolut das ist
genau das gleiche
ja also viel erfolg hat man das st